make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
all right what's going on guys this is
Rob and today we are taking one of the
most fearsome characters in the Marvel
Universe and asking what would happen if
they were to gain possession of one of
the most powerful artifacts in the DC
Universe the orange lantern ring and I
think the first thing that we have to
work out is how does Galactus acquire
the orange Lantern ring in the first
place so surely everyone who's watching
this knows the deal with Galactus that
he goes around the universe devouring
planets because that's the only way to
satiate the intense hunger that he feels
now to help him do this he's employed a
series of heralds to find planets
suitable to consume and the current
Herald of Galactus as of the time this
video is coming out is Thor now we are
gonna make a couple of assumptions here
right as most of you guys know Thor is
currently The Herald of Galactus in
order to help him find a handful of
planets that will allow him to consume
the black winter and Thor's response is
however many people on those planets die
it's not the biggest thing because the
universe is at stake here so basically
the needs of the few outweigh the needs
of the many what we're going to assume
is that under any normal circumstance
that Thor serves Galactus in a starkly
different way then as it's been done by
heralds of the past and this since the
Thor has a much stronger moral compass
than any of the previous Herald probably
even stronger than Silver Surfer and
that Thor is going to do everything he
can to make sure that Galactus takes as
few innocent lives as possible and so
the idea is that Thor goes to SIF who's
taken over for Heimdall as the guardian
of the Bifrost following his death and
tells her to try and locate planets that
are devoid of innocent life that he can
direct Galactus to now due to some sort
of cosmic anomaly SIF is able to extend
her vision beyond the boundaries of the
model universe and locates a planet
called Okara which is just bursting with
energy but seems to have no innocent
life on it at all and so Thor thinks
that this is basically perfect and he
tells Galactus about this planet and
then they go to it now immediately
Galactus is like this planet shouldn't
be here something's definitely wrong
i-i've seen this how Galactus talks at
this point Larfleeze the orange lantern
approaches Galactus and Thor and is not
about to let this planet be consumed
without a fight now Thor initially
considers moving in since he knows the
planet is inhabited but he immediately
senses that Larfleeze is anything but
innocent and he knows that now Galactus
knows about Okara that he isn't leaving
without feasting on his energy and so we
basically get an epic battle between
Thor and Larfleeze which goes on for
while without either able to gain the
upper hand until Galactus decides that
he's tired of waiting and blasts
Larfleeze back down to the planet's
surface and then begins consuming the
planet now not long into this process
however if Galactus starts noticing this
something's wrong that this is not like
any energy he's ever consumed in the
past and then it's changing it and so we
know this due to the fact that the
orange power battery is housed on the
planet and Galactus is essentially
tapping into that power now still
Galactus finds himself unable to stop
feeding on that energy in fact he wants
to devour as much of it as possible and
so when he's absorbed the entirety of
the planets energy including the orange
power battery Galactus is transformed
into an orange lantern and this spells
disaster for the entirety of the Marvel
Universe now in addition to as nearly
insatiable hunger Galactus is also
motivated by insatiable grief just a bit
of background on the orange Lantern
Corps for those you guys who aren't
familiar with it the orange lantern
light represents greed on the emotional
spectrum and so anyone who dons an
orange ring or taps into the orange
power battery is motivated only by greed
from that point forward now usually this
means they simply want to hoard as much
stuff as they can't but Galactus is
really beyond material possessions and
so I thought it would be an interesting
twist that instead of desiring things he
ends up desiring as much energy as he
can consume going well beyond what he
needs to survive and so he sets out
across the Marvel Universe leaving a
trail of broken worlds in his wake now
realize in the new danger that Galactus
poses to the universe Thor rushes back
to earth to warn the Avengers teammates
who quickly call in the Fantastic Four
due to their prior experience with
Galactus and so Thor describes what
happened but Reed Richards is unable to
come up with any plausible explanation
as he's never heard of any kind of
orange light capable of transforming
someone into a voracious greed monster
and so to try and find out more about
this mysterious force Reed goes with
Thor to space to the now dead planet
Okara to see what information they can
gather and read soon realizes what
Galactus did that Okara
should not have been in the Marvel
Universe that it was clearly from a
different universe based on the readings
Reed was getting but the opening in
space-time that allowed it to travel to
their universe no longer appears to be
open and so Reed ultimately states that
he was hoping that he could access the
place that the light originated perhaps
they could find something there to help
them rid themselves of it now
as readers we know that in fact
something does exist in the DC Universe
that would help their newfound problem
the Blue Lantern ring which is able to
negate the effects of the orange Lantern
ring and so read sets to work trying to
find a way to reopen the doorway into
this other universe but in case he fails
a contingency needs to be in place and
so while he works on finding a way to
the DC universe the Avengers and the
Fantastic Four will seek out perhaps the
only artifact in the Marvel Universe
that will be able to stop Galactus the
casket of ancient winners that's not
true that's a dumb idea
it's the ultimate nullifier but the
ultimate nullifier for those of you guys
who don't know is a device that is said
to be the only weapon in the universe
which Galactus fears however since the
nola fire also appears to be part of
Galactus he can recall it to himself
seemingly at will and so the team will
have to sneak aboard Galactus his world
ship to retrieve it without him knowing
and so what happens is that the heroes
split into two teams
Thor takes one team consisting of
Invisible Woman she-hulk Captain Marvel
and Captain America to Galactus as world
ship hah - to retrieve the ultimate
nullifier while Reed Richards and the
Black Panther try to devise a way to
reopen the gateway to the DC Universe
and the thing stays behind with them to
fly them back to the place the Gateway
was after they figure it out and so the
Human Torch also volunteers to accompany
them on their mission suggesting that if
anyone could survive the trip between
universes it would be him due to being
able to exist as a pure form of energy
now because read and T'Challa are
extremely smart and because of their
intelligence they realize that they need
to move the pot along they find a way to
recreate the cosmic anomaly that opened
the door between the two universes that
can only be explained using the most
ridiculous comic book science terms
imaginable
yes that's what that's what we need we
just need like like weather like read
how'd you do it he can just take up a a
page out of like I don't like the flash
TV show right with like Barry how did
you do that he's like Speed Force man I
ain't gotta explain it like it really
needs to be the same way right it's just
like read how'd you do that science and
like that's it that's all you did and so
they go to the planet Okara and attempt
to reopen the gateway now they are
initially successful in reopening the
gateway but when the Human Torch goes
through it much to the terror of his
companions he's vaporized before their
very eyes not only does this doom his
plan to failure but it makes Reed wonder
if perhaps Galactus destroying the
universe would be preferable
- trying to explain to his wife why her
brothers atoms have now been dispersed
across the universe I wouldn't want to
have to do that but we cut the Thor's
team and their attempt to procure the
ultimate nullifier now Thor is the first
to enter Galactus a ship under the
pretense of meeting with Galactus to
plead with him to stop his rampage and
spare the universe this is a tough pill
for Thor to swallow but he also puts his
pride aside and plays the role knowing
that Galactus needs to be distracted so
that the ultimate nullifier can be
secured without his detection now as the
two of them argue with Galactus telling
Thor to find him more planets to devour
because he must acquire all the energy
he can't the rest of the team enters the
world ship an Invisible Woman becomes
invisible and begins searching for the
nullifier now after a short time she
finds it and then takes it but doing so
sets off an alarm in Galactus his brain
as a part of himself has now been taken
from him and so Galactus blasts Thor
through the wall of the ship and into
space while the rest of the Avengers
team escape the ship with the ultimate
nullifier now as they make their way to
their ship they find that mr. fantastics
team has joined them outside of Galactus
ship but he's joined by most of the
cosmic heroes in the Marvel Universe the
Silver Surfer beta ray bill the
guardians of the galaxy Nova pretty much
all of the heroes you can think of now
Reed explains that things on his and
went south and he put out a distress
call that was answered in droves Reed
takes the ultimate nullifier from sue
and explains what happened to Johnny
now Sue's heartbroken but there's no
time to mourn because Galactus is pretty
pissed off and the only option they have
is to fight and so it's an
all-hands-on-deck situation with even
the earthbound heroes Donny space suits
and venturing off of their ships and
into the battle there was a lot of
firepower here with heroes like the
Silver Surfer and Thor aided by the
power cosmic
Captain Marvel Nova and others and for a
brief moment it looks like they may be
able to mount a meaningful defense
against Galactus but then everything
suddenly changes when Galactus summons
an army of orange light constructs now
unbeknownst to our heroes but known to
us as the orange lantern ring allows its
wheeler to absorb the energy from its
victims and transform them into
hardlight constructs which they came in
command as an orange Lantern Corps army
of sorts and so in the case of Galactus
this means that he has billions and
billions of these soldiers at his
command as he's consumed multiple
planets after absorbing the orange land
in matter and so as heroes begin to fall
before Galactus is horde Reed realizes
that the plan was doomed before it even
started
that Galactus will win if he doesn't do
something drastic and he readies the
ultimate nullifier for detonation
knowing that everyone in the vicinity
will likely die but that the universe
itself may still be safe and so before
he can detonate it however if vanishes
from his hand and Reed and the surviving
heroes turn around to see none other
than the Living Tribunal himself now for
those of you guys who may not be
familiar with the Living Tribunal he's
considered the second most powerful
entity in the Marvel Universe behind
only the one above all and his job is to
judge and correct anything that may
throw off the cosmic balance of the
Marvel Universe and so when he shows up
you know it's serious business and so
all the fighting stops as Galactus
simply just awaits judgment and so the
Living Tribunal explains that he cannot
allow the ultimate nullifier to be
detonated as Galactus is a necessary
element of the cosmic fabric of the
universe and then erasing him from
existence would have catastrophic
consequences however Galactus is greed
fuel rampage throughout the universe
also threatens the cosmic balance of the
universe and cannot be allowed to
continue
and so the Living Tribunal strips
Galactus of the orange power battery and
he hides it away in a pocket universe
that he created so it can never be
accessed again he declines however to
bring back Johnny Storm or resurrect any
of the planets Galactus has devoured as
she determines that the universe can
function perfectly well without them and
that he's not one to intervene
unnecessarily and so with Galactus no
longer under the control of the orange
light he goes back to fulfilling his
role as normal and the heroes that
survived the battle go back to earth or
wherever it was they came from to mourn
those that fell now here's the cool
thing I imagine a lot of you guys
probably thought that we were gonna
bring back Johnny Storm right they're
like Johnny Storm is like he vaporized
like we didn't really vaporize he just
kind of disappeared he's in the DC
Universe he rattles the blue lanterns
and then brings like all the blue
lanterns to the Marvel Universe and they
saved today wrong I'm gonna be awesome
till I totally do a 180 and just like
like spin you guys on your heads I
thought it'd be cool well that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here two
comments explain it make sure you guys
have the sub button to become part of
the Rob core if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and I
will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]